so these Dragon Ball auras in one piece
are getting a lot of heat right now so
let's talk about it while the auras in
the one piece anime can look fantastic
and often help Elevate scenes thanks to
creative color work and a greater sense
of power there's two issues that I think
cause a lot of upset in people the first
is that sometimes the compositing team
who add the auras to the episodes go way
overboard to the point of actually
masking the animation detail altogether
and upsetting the animators themselves
as a result the other issue is that
sometimes individual directors don't
quite get how auras represent power
within the series
the thing is when it works it really
works and ultimately the one o'ark is
the best one piece has ever looked it's
by far the best looking long form anime
on TV right now by a country mile so at
least to me while I think Aura critics
have some valid points let's maybe try
and talk about it in a way that's a bit
more balanced and a little less toxic
huh